[Music]
is this kind of the love nest that we're
in we were looking for a place for me
and Terry to
buy someday and then we walked in here
and I went
how's this for an exclusive a tour of
Heather dubrow's 14 million dollar
Penthouse who did Heather and her
plastic surgeon husband Terry use as
their real estate agent selling sunsets
Heather Ray El Moussa so we step off the
elevator and you walk into this this is
it I mean this has always been my dream
give me the rundown of the space like
how many rooms do we got bathrooms all
that so originally this apartment was a
three bedroom three and a half bath but
the previous owner changed it to a two
bedroom I guess we could call this the
great room you can see the entire city
the 5300 square foot pinthouse in La
which she calls a crash pad was actually
designed by a fashion icon what's really
cool about this place is it's the first
home that Roberto Cavalli's ever done in
the United States so what does that mean
what it means is he and his team
designed every square inch of this place
and actually Roberto Cavalli designed
some of the furniture rooms self the
team that did this is incredible they
brought over 60 crates from Italy and a
few crates from Spain the chandeliers
are custom Murano Glass the parquet
floors are all custom everything was
picked out everything was just thought
about thought about and they even
brought the crew over from Italy to do
the installation it's a natural stone
dining table and you can see Roberto
Cavalli's initials in there this bar was
actually built in Italy and they shipped
it here already assembled what's the
price tag on something like that I don't
know but I didn't pay for it well I
guess I did because it's like wife math
we're here about two three nights a week
it used to be that we'd you know come up
to LA to have work to do maybe have
dinner and then have to Trek home but
now we have a place to stay a crash pad
yes a not too shabby crash not too
shabby crash bag her famous neighbors
include Rihanna and Candy Spelling and
yeah no Chateau Dubrow is complete
without a wall of thousands worth of
bubbly not as big as the last champagne
wall but it does the trick yeah I think
I think you're just fine there's still a
few dozen bottles in there
we just drink slower
all right what's next okay
um let's go to the kitchen
this is the kitchen wow I just want to
show you the details of this place are
so amazing the way they designed the
door so these this door in particular is
suede and it's got lacquer and marble
it's like the house is wearing Cavalli
not just designed by Cavalli it's so
true but you know it's funny because
when you think of Cavalli you usually
think of crazy patterns and colors right
and
so
have you used this kitchen yet no I love
having guests I'll be hitting you up for
a stay yeah you should you know really I
do a bloody mary bar in the morning okay
you don't have to sell me any farther to
cook but I'm really good at you know at
booze yeah